EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: First
off, I want to say, thank you
guys so much for coming today.
I know it's getting
towards the end of the day,
so thanks for coming to the
talk and having patience.
My name is Eitan Marder-Eppstein
and I'm an engineering manager
on Daydream.
And today, I want
to talk to you a bit
about virtual reality at Google.
And what we're planning on
doing and, sort of, give you
a glimpse of the future.
Unfortunately, the product
that I'm going to talk
about today isn't yet
available in China,
but it's something that
we want to make available.
And I want you guys to have
a preview of what's going on.
So to get started,
this is Daydream.
I guess, maybe, by a show
of hands, how many of you
have seen Daydream before?
OK, pretty good.
So Daydream is Google's
first mobile VR offering.
It consists of a headset
paired with Google Pixel
put-ons in the controller.
But it's going to be coming
to a lot more phones as well.
So there's a Daydream compatible
spec that phones can meet
and they can come out.
And compared to a lot of
offerings in the space,
it's relatively cheap.
So when you think about
buying a VR headset,
it can be very, very
expensive right now.
And Google really wants
to bring VR to the masses.
So we're offering
Daydream view, in the US,
right now, as an add on to
the Pixel phone for $79.
And it launched on November 10.
So it's a relatively new
product in the space,
but we're very excited
to see how it takes off.
The rest of the
talk is going to be
about the platform, about
some of the developer tools,
and about designing
for VR, which
I think is a unique challenge.
And to start with,
you know, we've
already got a lot
of progress here.
There are already people
who have built applications,
and studios, and
close partners that
have released their applications
on the Daydream platform.
So with Launch, we actually
have a number of apps out there.
And I encourage you to go by
our booth and check some of them
out.
All right so, let's
start with the platform.
I think Daydream
is unique in that,
normally when we
talk about platform,
we talk about some
piece of hardware.
We talk about a new phone,
we talk about a new watch,
we talk about a computer.
But for Daydream, the
platform is really you, right?
The entire point
of virtual reality
is to trick your
body and your senses
into believing that you're
somewhere that you're not.
And when we do this,
one of the things
that's really,
really important is
trying to trick all of
your senses at once.
So when you think about the
actual world, the real world,
when I move my head
around, my inner ear,
my vestibular system, actually
notices that I'm moving.
There's fluid in
my ear that notices
that I'm moving my head.
And, at the same time, my eyes
are tracking out in space.
And my eyes also notice
that I'm moving my head.
And the latency between
them, the delay,
is zero milliseconds.
Right?
As soon as I move my head, my
inner ear notices and my eyes
notice as well.
But when you think about this
process for a cell phone,
it's not quite the same.
So, here, my inner ear
notices right away, again,
that I'm moving my head.
But now, before I
can update my eyes,
before I can change what's on
the display in front of me,
a bunch of stuff has to happen.
So first there are inertial
sensors in the phone.
Accelerometers and
a gyroscope, that
have to notice that the
motion is happening.
Then I need to do some
processing on the CPU
to decide what
I'm going to draw.
Then I need to actually
draw it on the GPU
and then that needs
to go to my eyes.
And that all adds up.
This is, sort of what you would
see on a traditional cell phone
processing pipeline.
And here it's 85 milliseconds.
So it adds up.
What we know is that we
need to get this down
to below 20 milliseconds.
So 20 milliseconds is
kind of that magic number.
That time where your
inner ear and your eyes,
even though there's a delay,
you don't actually notice it.
It still feels good
and you don't get sick.
And screwing this
up is really bad.
Right?
Like we make people sick.
Bad VR makes people sick.
If you're sick in VR,
you're sick in real life.
So we've done a lot of work
to get our motion to photon
latency, the time from when
you move your head to when
light enters your eyes, below
this magic 20 milliseconds.
Another challenge that we
have in designing for Daydream
is that we have a mobile device.
So on a mobile device you're
dealing with six or seven watts
of power draw.
It's not a very powerful
desktop machine.
You know, we're
competing, I guess,
with these power plants
that draw over 600 watts.
And so we have to
play a lot of tricks
and be very conscious in the
way that we develop applications
to make sure that we're hitting
these power requirements.
And there's a lot
that we've done
there to help develop this out.
So here are some of the things
that we've worked really,
really hard on to
both reduce the power
requirements for Daydream as
well as to reduce the motion
to photon latency.
So the first one is that
Daydream compatible phones
have low persistence displays.
They have [INAUDIBLE]
displays that refresh very,
very quickly.
They also have very high
performance mobile CPUs
and GPUs.
So the Pixel phone is using
Qualcomm's top of the line A20
processor.
So we do as much
processing as possible
in a mobile form factor.
And then the second,
or the third,
piece is low latency sensing.
So we want to know as
quickly as possible
when you've actually turned
your head to the left
or to the right, or up or down.
And these are the
components that
make a phone Daydream ready.
So we want to make sure
people don't get sick
when they use our products.
And so we have this
specification where, you know,
you as a manufacturer need
to meet these requirements
in order to build a
Daydream ready phone.
The other thing that we've done
is we've worked really hard
in the Android N to
build into the platform
itself, mechanisms
for making sure
that Android is a really,
really high quality
platform for virtual reality.
So the first piece of that is to
[INAUDIBLE] [? performance. ?]
Normally when you've got
your phone CPU, it spikes.
It can go really high and
really high performance.
And then it goes back low.
And that's the normal way that
applications work on phones.
They sort of need a
lot of performance
for a very short amount of time.
But with VR, we're
changing that paradigm.
And now you need
to be able to run
with a good amount
of performance
for a long period of time.
And so we've introduced
sustained performance load,
which throttles
the clock rate down
to give you overall more
performance than you
would have. and keep the
device from overheating.
If you ran it at full
throttle all the time,
the device would overheat
very, very quickly.
And so we've built in mechanisms
to the operating system
itself to ensure
that you can run VR
experiences for a lot of time.
The second piece that
we built into Android N
is very, very,
good head tracking.
So again, very quickly
going from that sensor
to being able to give
your application a pose
of a person's head as it moves.
And then the third piece is
that we've actually worked hard
with the Android team to build
a system UI that works in VR.
So when you think about
putting on a VR headset
with your phone, normal Android
doesn't make sense anymore,
it's designed for 2D.
But we've started to bring
pieces of Android into 3D.
So that you can have a very
good and solid experience in VR
in Android and we built
that into Android N itself.
This took a lot of hard
work from the Android team
and our team and we're
excited to continue
this in future Android
releases as well.
All right so here,
again, is the view.
You take your phone to
use this, under the latch,
put the phone in
the view, there's
an NFC reader, in
the headset itself,
that recognizes when
the phone is in.
And then you're in VR.
It also comes with a controller.
And you can see
that this controller
has three buttons on it.
So it's got a
clickable touchpad.
So that's actually
touch sensitive
so you can swipe
and gesture on it.
You can also press down.
And then it's got these
two other buttons.
So an app button that can be
used for application menus.
And then a home button
that can get you
back to Daydream
home, which I'll
talk about in a little bit.
The controller is also
really special in that it
provides a really
natural interface for VR.
So it can track its
orientation as well.
So inside of the
controller itself
are inertial sensors too.
So there's a gyroscope
and accelerometers inside
of the controller.
And this helps you understand
where it is in space.
So you can use it
as a laser pointer.
And we've also done
some work to hook it up
to an [? arm ?] model to, kind
of, fake six degree of freedom
motion in your applications.
All right so, at that point,
you've got your controller.
You put it on and you're
inside Daydream and--
slide changes.
This is what you see.
So we've worked
really hard, again,
to integrate Daydream
into Android itself.
And we've got a deep
integration, also,
with Google Play, so our store.
And you can browse
content in VR.
You don't have to leave
VR to browse content.
You can decide which
apps you want to buy,
you can see reviews from people.
I mean, this all happens
without having to leave VR
and it's all integrated to, sort
of, the same background that we
use normally at Google, which
is convenient for people.
And then the other thing
that we've built into it
is in-app purchases.
So we understand that
for a lot of developers,
it's important not to just
follow a premium model where
you might get people to buy
your application upfront.
But also to build
in-app purchases where
you can view premium models.
And sort of take advantage of
the traditional monetization
techniques available
to you on Google.
All right so that, in a
nutshell, is the platform.
That's what we're delivering.
Now I want to talk a little
bit about developer tools.
All right, so for
Daydream, you're
inherently developing in 3D.
It's an environment where you
have to create 3D content,
offer it, and put it
out into the world.
And so we offer a
couple of different ways
to develop for the product.
The first one is
Android, which is
what you're all familiar with.
It's just stock
Android development.
And this makes a
lot of sense if you
want to do your own 3D render.
But we've also
work really, really
hard to provide integrations
with popular game engines.
So the first one
is Unreal Engine,
and we've worked
with Epic on that.
And the next one
is Unity Engine.
And these engines allow you
to get very quickly started
with 3D content and
sort of bring it
into this virtual reality world.
So I'm going to
walk through each
of these just really quick.
And give you, like, the 30
second to a minute getting
started guide for all
of these different ways
you can develop for VR.
So the first one
is the Android NDK.
You'll want version 1.0.2 or
higher of Google's Android SDK.
And you can get it on
GitHub right there.
And this is kind
of how it looks.
So here you can see we've
got our normal activity
in [? Java. ?] And we're
going to create a GL surface
view, the same way that we
would normally render open GL
contents in Androids.
And above it, you'll see
there's something special where
we've created this GVR layout.
So that's going to give
us access in native code,
actually, to the
Google VR contents.
And that's what
we'll use to interact
with the data-reading system
to get the information we
need for virtual reality.
Then the rest of it
is pretty standard.
So on creation of
your service you're
actually going to call
through the JNI to native code
to hook it up to the rendering
engine of your choice.
And then on draw
frame you're also
going to call through
the JNI to native code
to view the rendering work.
And then at the bottom there,
there are just some settings.
So one is setting scan
[? line raising ?]
to be enabled.
So one of the things that we
can do to reduce the latency.
Of VR is if you think
about how you write
pixels across the screen.
It actually doesn't
happen all at once.
There's kind of a line that
moves across the screen.
And so we actually write
just after that line,
so we're always following it.
And writing directly
into that train buffer.
And then we're just
going to say, OK,
we're going to set this
surface view as the one we're
going to render.
So then inside of
your native code,
you'll remember there were
those two methods that we
[? helped. ?] So, here, we
just initialize the GVR API.
Google VR API.
And then, you can see that it
will give you a recommended
render target size.
So what this is doing is,
based on your configuration
of your viewer, it's
going to tell you what
size you need to render to.
And this is important
because for VR,
when you look
through the lenses,
you actually need to
see a distorted image.
The lenses are really great
in that they sort of allow
you to see very far
away when the screen is
very close to you.
But you have to apply
distortion to your image
in order to make it seem
like the world looks right,
distortion-wise, when you
look through the lens.
Then you just passed your render
target into your frame buffer
and then you're off and running.
And then inside a
draw frame, you're
going to get the head pose,
again, from the GVR API.
So you don't have to do any
work to get the head pose.
You just get it for free.
You know exactly where
the person is looking.
You draw the left and
right eyes normally.
You don't have to
apply any distortion.
And then you'll
see, at the bottom,
you actually call
this distort off
screen frame buffer to screen.
So that, again, is using
the characteristics
of the lens based on the
rendered target size,
as well, to view the
proper distortion.
It just takes care
of things for you.
It'll draw the image
properly on the screen.
There are a couple
of initial settings
that you need to set
in your manifest.
One is just to say, I
want to use VR mode.
And the other one is to use
VR high performance mode.
So before I talked about
sustained performance mode
in Android, this
way of throttling
the CPU to be able to get longer
running application times.
And there are actually
two different modes.
So one is high
performance, which
is good for games
and applications
where you're only going to be
running for 30 to 45 minutes,
on average.
And then the other one is
just sustained performance,
and that will actually
run for an hour plus.
So that's really, really
good for multimedia content
and things like that.
And then there's
one additional thing
that you can do in your
manifest, which is just to say,
I am a VR app and I
am a Daydream app.
and that will allow
you to show up in,
sort of, the Daydream
home application.
So that's Native.
which is relatively
complicated, I
guess, compared to our
other integrations.
So now, I'll talk about how you
get started with Unreal Engine.
And this is much quicker.
If you want, you can download
Unreal Engine 4.13 or later.
And have Daydream built in.
And you can go to the link
right there to find it.
So in Unreal Engine,
you just select
that you want to use a plug-in.
And then inside of
the plug-in's menu,
you'll see that there are
a number of offerings.
And you'll want to enable Google
VR and you'll want to, I guess,
deselect all of our
competitors that
are also offered in Unreal.
So you do that.
And then you're going to
set, on your target hardware,
you just want to make sure
that you select mobile tablets
and scaleable to the M3.
And then there's
one setting that
is a little bit non-intuitive.
So you're going to disable
the default touch interface.
Because Unreal Engine has
a joystick, by default.
And then you're going to
disable mobile HDR because it
interferes with the
stereo distortion
process that I described
in Native before.
And then you just target
Android Level 24, so Android N,
and you're off.
That's it.
Now you can use Unreal Engine
like you normally would.
You place your camera and you
get VR rendering for free.
Unity is equally simple.
So for Unity there's a
technical preview that's out.
And actually new versions of
Unity will have this built in.
But you can find the technical
preview at this link.
And for Unity--
So for Unity 5.6 or greater,
it will have this built in.
So there you go to your
player settings menu,
on the upper right.
And you'll just select,
Virtual Reality Supported,
there's just a check box.
And then you select
Daydream from the drop down.
And then there are some
additional parameters
you can set on your
[? desk buffer ?] format.
You'll want to, again,
target the Android N APRs.
And you're off.
That's it.
For Unity it's
very, very simple.
You can build your application
as you normally would.
And then you're off and running.
So the next piece that I want
to talk about a little bit
is Designing for Daydream,
or for VR in general.
I think that VR is a really
challenging and interesting
space.
And we actually have
more of an obligation,
I think, to our users than
we do in other applications.
I think in VR it's
very, very easy
to elicit an emotional
response from the people who
are using your experiences.
It's very easy to
frighten people
and it's also easy
to make people sick.
So there are some
things to consider
when designing for Daydream
that I'll talk about.
The first one is, I
think, you should really
forget that you're
using a phone.
Normally, when
people use phones,
we think about them out, on
the go, at a coffee shop,
just very, very quickly checking
email or texting friends
or maybe playing a game on
the bus, something like that.
But we actually have studies,
some early studies coming in,
about how people use VR.
And, I think, that
what you'll see here
is that they're not actually
using their mobile VR
devices out at a coffee shop.
They're using them in their
living room or their bedroom,
they're using them at home.
And then the other
thing to notice,
here, is that they're
actually using them
for a prolonged period of time.
So you're not operating with
this couple of minute session.
Now you're talking
about people using them
for 30 to 45 minutes, on
average, for playing games
or interactive experiences.
And you're talking about people
using them for an hour plus,
when they're viewing
media content.
So you actually have your users
in VR for a long, long time.
And I think you should
almost think about VR as,
sort of, reading a book
or telling a story.
You have an opportunity
to engage with your users
for a long period of time.
And that opens up different
possibilities for you
and sort of changes
how you design.
It's not quite mobile design,
it's something in between.
The second thing that I
think is really useful,
is that you should
use your hands.
I think one of the
things that makes
VR so compelling, at least with
Daydream, is this controller.
It really provides a
feeling of presence
to be able to interact with
your environment and point
to different things.
And again, you have a clickable
touchpad available to you,
and you also have an app
button and a home button.
You can actually make
use of the controller
and track how it's
moving through space
and change the interaction.
And there are some
very, very clever things
you can do with the controller.
So we've provided
some examples for you
that you can download
off our developer site.
But use the controller
to do things like scroll
through paginated
lists of image titles,
if you want to do
video feedback.
Or we've done a
number of experiments
about how we can actually
push the boundaries
in the [? key holder. ?]
So in the upper left,
you'll see that we're
using it to play mini
golf, just as a putter.
In the upper right, we're
using it to navigate it
around the solar system.
In the lower left,
we're, I guess,
flipping pancakes on the beach.
And in the lower right, we were
hitting baseballs with a bat.
So even though the controller
has relatively simple
sensing in it.
I think you can use it to create
really powerful and immersive
applications.
And it's something that
is a major differentiator,
I think, for Daydream
over other VR platforms,
certainly in the mobile space
that are available to them.
The other thing I want
to say about Daydream
is that you should really keep
your experiences comfortable.
I was talking earlier
about how, you know,
we have a great responsibility
when designing for VR.
And Google has gone to
incredible amounts of effort
to make sure that the viewer
itself and the controller
itself feels comfortable.
So we realize that
this is in some ways
a mix between a phone
and apparel, in a way.
And that is something
that you're going
to be wearing on your face.
So we've taken great
care to design Daydream
with very soft materials that
feel good on your face, that
fit over glasses,
as well, because we
know that a lot of
people wear glasses.
And we've designed
the controller
to fit in your
hands, to be light
and to be comfortable
in your hands.
Another thing is that, I think,
a lot of us, when we work,
sit in chairs that
look kind of like this.
And so it's very tempting to
design VR experiences that
are full 360.
Because swivel chairs
are great for full 360.
But the reality is
that most of our users
are sitting in chairs
that look like this.
They don't actually
rotate around.
And many people
use VR in bed and
in other comfortable settings.
So when you're thinking about
designing VR experiences,
then you kind of want
to think about a quarter
of a sphere in front of you.
Like, what are the areas that
are comfortable for someone to,
sort of, rotate around
in a seat and see.
Rather than forcing them
to turn around awkwardly,
as if they're on a swivel
chair when they're not.
And then there's motion.
So this again gets
into this disconnect
between your inner
ear and your eyes.
If you go into VR
experience and you just
start moving someone
very, very quickly,
it's a great way to
make them throw up.
And so there are a few
different classes of motion
that actually are informing
users of when an app is
submitted to the store.
So the first one
is no motion where
you're just sitting in a chair.
And you're, maybe, looking
at a screen in front of you
and you're not
moving very quickly.
The second one is
moderate motion,
maybe you're moving
at a walking speed.
And this tends to be OK.
People can tolerate this.
But the third one
is extreme motion
where you're flying
and moving very,
very quickly through space.
And I think that especially when
you get into the third piece,
it's really important to apply
techniques like tunneling, so
teleporting from one place
to another or, sort of,
collapsing the field of view.
So you just have one point in
front of you that's moving fast
and the rest of the
scene is stable.
And we're working
to release tools
that will help you, as
developers, build experiences
that are comfortable, even
you're moving into these more
and more intense motion realms.
And then another last
piece of designing for VR
is that you can make
people really afraid.
I don't know how many
of you have been in VR
and tried to step off
the edge of the cliff.
But many people have a fear of
heights and they just cannot do
it.
They cannot step forward.
So that's one.
You can also feel
very, very awkward
when a virtual object
intersects your physical body.
You look down and
you're very confused,
it's just feels wrong.
You can make people feel
very claustrophobic.
You can make people
feel agoraphobic
where there's a huge
space in front of you
and it's disconcerting.
Being stabbed in VR is not fun.
You actually feel a
response even though nothing
happens to you actually.
And being crushed in VR is also
a very, very scary experience.
So these are things
that might be
fun to just try and experience
to see what your reaction is.
But it's not something
that you want
you do to your ultimate user.
And then the last
piece that I think
everyone forgets with VR is
just how powerful audio is.
So when you think
about rendering a tree,
you can think about rendering
this very, very high quality
tree.
You want to give the idea that
the tree is actually there,
that the wind is blowing
through the tree,
that birds are chirping.
But another way to
render this tree
is to use, sort of a low poly
version of the tree-- oh,
sorry.
And instead use audio to give
a feeling that you're there.
And we have a spatial audio
SDK that I encourage all of you
to go look at and try out.
That really allows you to
feel like you're there.
You can listen to the wind
and hear the birds chirp.
And give the illusion
that this tree
is real just through sound.
And I think if you
think about sound
as, like, bang for your
buck, in terms of watts
per level of immersion.
In terms of power per
level of immersion,
audio is really, really good.
Because it doesn't take a
lot of power to generate.
But it does give you the
feeling of being there.
Our audio SDK also allows
you to change the sound
based on the environment
that you're in.
So if you think about
walking though a forest
and what that sounds
like, relative to walking
through a spaceship and
what that sounds like.
It's very different.
It depends on the material
properties of space.
And so our SDK will actually
model the material properties
of whatever space you
design in Unity or Unreal.
And change the sound
that is played,
based on the properties of
the space that you're in.
We're still learning a lot.
All of this came from a lot of
experimentation that we did.
We have a group called
Daydream labs, that essentially
just tinkers with VR.
We try new things, we try
to see if they'll work--
we see what breaks
and what doesn't.
And we produce those learnings
and try to share them with you.
And we actually have a
number of experiments
that we've released as
our controller playground.
So we work a lot with the
Daydream controller to figure
out what felt good
and what didn't.
And we have, I think,
16 different demos
that are available to you.
So if you want to get started.
If you want to play with what it
feels like to use the Daydream
controller, you know, [? view ?]
magic wands and swing bats
and flip pancakes, you
can do that all in VR.
And the last thing that I'll
show, I guess, before I end,
is some work that's been
done by our partners.
I think it's really
interesting to see
what other people have
produced for a given
product and platform.
It's really early days here.
But you can check
out some of the stuff
that people are
building already.
So I'll play this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: OK,
so that, in a nutshell,
is Daydream.
Normally I would point
to the dot-com link.
But actually we have also
launched our Chinese version
of our developer documentation.
So if you go to
developers.google.cn/vr,
you can find everything that
I've been talking about here
and more.
Also you should make sure
to check out our booth
if you haven't already.
So we're demoing a few
things at the booth.
The first one is Daydream,
so you can actually
try some of the applications
that I showed here.
The second one is Google's built
VR products for the HTC Vive
as well.
So you can try out Google
Earth and you can also
try out Tilt Brush, so
a painting application.
They come really
highly recommended.
And then right after this talk,
my colleague [? Manusan ?]
will be talking about
Project Tango, which
is Google's augmented reality
offering and augmented reality
phones.
And those are, actually,
coming to China very soon,
so I encourage you to
listen to that as well.
I think I do have some
time for questions.
I wasn't going to
take questions,
but I'll take a couple
from the audience.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: So
I guess the question was--
for Daydream, what's
the most important?
Is it the UI, user interaction,
or is it the graphic quality?
And it's a good question.
There's no easy answer to it.
I think it's actually both.
I think first and
foremost, reducing
that latency, that motion to
photon latency I talked about,
between when you move your
head to when your eyes actually
see the screen, is
the most important,
in that it keeps you
from getting sick.
But then the UI
designed after that
is also very, very
[? important. ?]
OK, let's go, maybe, there.
In the stripes.
AUDIENCE: I have
tried Daydream today.
[INAUDIBLE] and then I find
[? to ?] [? propose. ?]
[INAUDIBLE] it's an
[INAUDIBLE] for biographics.
The programming is [INAUDIBLE]
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
So the two questions
were one, that Daydream is still
uncomfortable with glasses.
And then, two, that you have no
context for what's around you
and so you can bump
into things and it's
sort of dangerous in that way.
So, for the first one.
One thing that
I've found, we did
work hard to try to make
it good with glasses,
but you have to tighten
it really tight.
It's really important
to get the strap tight.
I think that we are going to
be doing other iterations.
We're going to be
learning from the design.
And so in future iterations
of the viewer, I think,
you'll see us work even
harder for glasses.
But one tip is to
really tighten it
a lot for when you
have glasses on.
For the second piece,
which is, can you
be aware of your environment.
So, for right now, we
suggest that people
use Daydream in a safe space
without moving around a lot.
I think that you
will see, over time--
there are systems if you
look at what's going on
in the desktop VR space.
You know, there's at
least Guardian from HTC
to keep you from hitting things.
But I think it's a problem
that is going to need research.
And need the community
to work on it.
Like, I think, a lot of
people are thinking about it
and realizing, OK, if
you use VR in your home,
you need to understand
where things are.
So I expect it's something
that we and also others
in the space, will be working
on in the next couple years.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
So the question
was about the space is
moving really, really fast.
So as a developer, you want
to buy a Daydream device
and you want to develop for it.
But you're worried
that your device
will be outdated at some time.
And that could happen.
I think that the space
is moving really quickly.
I think you'll see
products come out.
And in Google we have made a
commitment to Daydream devices,
like, we're working on
making more Daydream devices
and bringing this concept
to a lot of people.
So it is a device
that we're planning
on supporting for some time.
That's why we
launched the product.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
The question
is when will the
platform be stable.
I think it's actually
quite stable right now.
Like, I think we
have a number of apps
that are production
apps that are going out
and have many, many users.
And, I think, today is a good
day to start developing for it.
We've worked really, really
hard over the last year
to get this ready and we put it
into a flagship phone for us,
which is the Pixel.
So I think today is a good day.
Yeah.
In the--
AUDIENCE: First of all,
thank you for your speech.
And my question is, what is
the difference between Daydream
SDK or Qualcomm SDK?
The advantage of
Google Daydream SDK?
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
So the question was,
I guess, the Google VR SDK
versus Qualcomm's VR SDK.
AUDIENCE: Yes, absolutely.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: So,
I guess, the Google SDK
is deeply integrated
into Android
and also includes our
controller and special tools
to actually use the controller.
So Google VR SDK is integrated,
as well, into Unity and Unreal.
So it's specifically made
for Daydream devices.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
advantages over video play?
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
Over video play?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
So, I guess,
we support DRM video,
which is something
that a lot of companies want.
It's secure video, I guess.
But for playing
360 video, I think
we're similar in many ways.
We support DRM video
and then we also
support use of the control.
I think those are--
and we're targeting
our Daydream
platform which allows
us to have very low latency.
AUDIENCE: OK, Thank you.
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: I
guess the question is that
how to build a Daydream app,
how to put it on Play right now.
I think, for China, we still
are working on our strategy.
For the Google Play store
elsewhere in the world,
it's just the normal processor.
So the normal way you
would put an app on Play
is the same for any [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
One more--
AUDIENCE: Actually
just following up
on the previous question,
so can you elaborate more
on your China strategy?
Is there a timeline and what's
the thing going to look like,
if you catch here?
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN: So
the question is, what is my--
our China strategy.
I knew I was going
to get this question.
I think it's a very
fair question to ask.
Right now, I do not have
any details to share
about our China strategy.
What I can say, is that we
do know China is important.
We have a history of putting
[? pies ?] into China.
Even in this space,
with the Tango phone.
But that's all I
can say right now.
I wish I had more for you.
All right, one more question.
All right.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
EITAN MARDER-EPPSTEIN:
So the question
is, what is the
difference between the HTC
Vive and Daydream?
How do we think about them
relative to each other?
So the main difference
between the HTC5 and Daydream
is Daydream is a
platform for mobile VR.
So it's using phones.
Whereas the HTC Vive is a
platform for desktop VR,
so it's using a very
powerful computer.
The HTC Vive is also
six degrees of freedom.
So it tracks you
as you move and has
controllers that do the same,
using this external tracking
system.
Whereas Daydream
is three degrees
of freedom for both the
controller and the headset.
I think, for Google,
we're excited
about the space in general.
And that's why you're seeing
us build some applications
for the HTC Vive as well.
We want to make sure that
Google products work really
well across the ecosystem.
So we're happy to build
applications for the Vive.
We're also happy to build the
applications for Daydream.
And we think that
Daydream has potential
to be really broadly adopted.
Like, a platform where a
lot of people can get on VR.
Whereas some of
the desktop systems
are a little bit more expensive.
I think that's all I
have time for right now.
Thank you guys, again, so much.
I'll be at the booth
or here afterwards.
And please do check out
the Tango talk, as well.
I think it'll be good.
So thank you, again.
[APPLAUSE]